[Music]
alright guys well this is my first time
doing this this lecture my greatest
losses and I think initially when when I
saw that I was going to be doing this
class I was kind of excited because I
thought it should be very easy to find a
number of games which I've lost I'm very
good at that but I then I actually
realized it's quite difficult because
the class is not called
my losses it's called my greatest losses
and then none of my losses are very
impressive you know it's nice when you
go down to go down in style go down
fighting so that your game may be
candidate for an exciting lecture like
this but I haven't played too many of
those which had actually made it easier
to find one so in the end it was very
easy this is a game I play it against
Ganguly Surya Shekhar Ganguly from India
he's a grandmaster has been for quite
some time
he's usually found above 2600 and
definitely does some work with the very
elite players in India so he's not only
very well prepared just as a chess
player himself but when you do a lot of
work for other strong players you
usually have to be better prepared than
than just for your own games you know
sometimes you're more polite when you go
to your friend's house than you are to
your own parents so when you're helping
out someone else you got to make sure
your your tactics and your theory and
your recommendations are airtight
because it's your skin your neck on the
line there so I was really excited for
this game I had never played him at the
time this was in 2015 so also in 2015 I
was still an international master and
this was played in the Edmonton
International that's in Canada I was a
norm tournament closed tournaments so
there were some invited foreign players
and Ganguly was one of them so I had the
white pieces
the game started d4 d5 and at the time
my horrible addiction to London system
had not yet festered
so I played c4 and this was pretty
standard for me at the time and even now
I've always been a d4 player ever since
I've been a decent player I think I
started with E for butts quickly
switched over and the Queens gambit is
something that I have have really played
for quite some time but the line that my
opponent chose to play against me is
actually kind of a unique one and sure
we all know about D takes c4 I mean at
the end of the day the Queens gambit
accepted is one of the most basic
variations you're gonna offer me a pawn
I'm gonna take it but after the movie
for gaining space in the center you
don't often see black play in a way
where he can successfully just take your
pawn on the second move of the game and
then hang on to it
there's not many variations where black
can play D takes c4 b5 and find a way to
keep his pond so this game was actually
an example of my opponent trying to do
that and using a line which he
definitely had prepared not necessarily
for this game but had prepared in
general and that line is after a four
okay if black plays B takes a four I
mean I think it's clear that all these
pawns are eventually gonna fall and
white is gonna be the one with the
center completely under his control so
it makes sense that my opponent would
play c6 and not a6 dropping the the pawn
because of this pin but although that
that might seem completely completely
obvious actually that's exactly what
happened the line continues here is c6
and okay if I put more pressure on the
pawn with Knight c3 if you play a six
technically that there should be the
exact same reaction pawn takes C takes
b5 and Knight takes b5 because I mean
this is
Elementary tactics Knight takes b5 rook
takes a8 and I'm winning and then my
opponent just took my knight it was kind
of a shock eight takes b5 so this is a
line and it is a line
my opponent wasn't just going crazy at
the board but this is actually a
variation a theoretical one at that
we're black voluntarily gives away the
Brooklyn 88 and he says okay the
resulting position is actually just
going to be an entire rook for an entire
piece just a whole exchange up for white
no pawns no gimmicks nothing he's just
saying that there's a very specific way
and you'll see in the game how black can
sort of attack White's Center and if
white just plays these normal logical
moves which I thought I was playing it's
actually quite easy to get to get in
trouble so Brooke takes a a of course I
mean I just lost the knight Bishop d7
with tempo hitting the rook and also
this pawn on e4 and Black's not really
actually intending to take it so if I
move my rook anywhere let's say R okay
one Black's not necessarily going to
play the move Bishop takes e4 here he
could but not usually the main reason is
that if you get a little greedy --nt and
take here first of all the move
b3 comes into consideration because if
you take it then I take on b5 and we
already sort of wish here that we maybe
had some more space for our King or some
more pieces developed and black is
already kind of I mean I'm gonna take a
b3 next and you don't really want to
play this but Bishop takes e4 makes the
most sense why is it not played well
black favors the movie six so that the
King has more room so that black can
play Bishop b4 check next turn and get
the pieces up very quickly what black
wants to do is develop with tempo
develop quickly and eventually say that
he can attack the center with maybe his
pieces maybe his pawns and I think in
this game you'll see kind of the the
natural way or the most concrete way to
to attack White's Center
ninety-two now 92 is an interesting move
right giving away this pawn and this is
actually these are some games that I
wanted to just mention is that these
aren't my games but these are ones to be
aware of if you're playing this position
is we can see the types of positions you
get are very unorthodox it's like what
what's going on here Black's you know
taking that Center pawn White's
voluntarily giving it up and saying okay
finally I get to get castle
play King h1 maybe play d5 at the end of
the day we are up that exchange but we
had to give a pawn back for it
now what would most of us play most of
us would probably play and move after
three because it's the most solid way to
defend the e4 pawn first of all it keeps
the e4 pawn I mean it's kind of crazy to
play this position and just give up your
one center pawn for nothing seemingly so
92 may be a good move but not the most
natural I mean f3 is clearly the most
natural so after f3 we we see that there
there may be a few reasons down the line
why my white might want his rook on a1
and white may want his rook on a - now I
had actually seen there was a good
chance he plays this line so before the
game I had checked out Rock a1 I checked
out rook a to and I decided that I would
play row K 2 instead of Rho K 1 with the
idea that later on
I'm gonna play this move b2 b3 and this
rook might be useful along the
second-ranked can enter the position
without let's say having to move my
Bishop on c1 if my rook was on a1 maybe
I'd have to develop all my pieces to use
my rook but here I thought well I'm a
genius
I'll play b3 swing the rope along the
second-ranked and get it into the action
so this is my game not route k1 but R
okay - you'll notice that the resulting
moves are kind of similar black still
wants to play e6 and similarly night e 2
is a very decent move for white but
again I was playing the most natural way
as
f 3 and of course it's the easiest way
to defend the center and the issue that
I have with this position is that when
you look at it with the engine the
engine says that white is doing
fantastic like really well
almost like +1 or something and +1
almost makes sense because technically
the material imbalance is is a rook for
a minor piece to rook for a knight here
but it's plus 1 so I just looked at plus
1 I think I played a few more moves when
I was preparing and I said ok he's not
gonna play this because it's plus 1 I
mean he's not gonna play into a position
where the evaluations not so good but
actually where I thought the variation
ended right here is probably where the
variation begins so I thought oh I play
f3 that's the end of the line plus 1 I'm
up clear exchange just get developed and
castle easy wasn't the case at all
actually there's been a lot of games and
they often start from this position
right here and black scores really well
despite the evaluation that was
something I had not looked at so had I
really prepared properly I should have
looked a little further should have
maybe looked at the games that were
played there I didn't do that I just
sort of checked the engine evaluation
and I saw this rookie - might be more
useful than row k1 which most people
were playing and so I just said ok if
you plays this line I'll do this turned
out he did play this line and I wasn't
really prepared for what was going to
come next after f3 she played knight c6
and again I almost look at this position
and think you know my moves are all very
natural how can they be wrong
92 can't go wrong with 92 getting my
knight developed guarding the pawn in
the center my next move is probably
gonna be this Bishop out to e3 and maybe
Queen d2 Knight c3 I thought wow this
just looks great and my opponent was
kind of unfazed Bishop before check he's
playing very quickly and it was a little
bizarre to me because I kept looking at
my position like what am I missing
what am I missing but it's just so solid
there can't be anything wrong with it
Bishop d2 Knight g7 now an ite 7 kind of
caught me by surprise again because I
thought okay
it's also possible I could take this
bishop and play brook a3 and while he
might have 93 I'm gonna take that and
because I was up in exchange if I give
back the exchange and went upon for it I
thought this should be good for me again
but I'm still a little bit away from
castling here so and it's also
absolutely not clear that blacks gonna
play 93 in fact I don't think he is but
I didn't I didn't end up doing that I
ended up playing this move
b3 mostly because I wanted to make use
of my rook Lynnae - and I thought well
if I played b3 if black takes then it's
always easy for me to play Queen takes
and what a genius I am with this Bishop
on before taking on D - because luck my
rook on a - I mean I actually look like
one of the smartest guys ever Brooklyn
a2 instead of on a1 now I get to play
Brooklyn a2 takes d2 guarding my deep on
at the same time so I thought okay
probably I thought that I would be
giving this this class maybe in a
different lecture like most brilliant
wins or something at the time when it
when I thought about this but luckily it
was good lecture material anyway so
didn't happen but of course that's one
of the main calculations and I thought
when I played rook aid to initially that
this is exactly how I want to do it I
want to play b3 use my rook on the
second rank and so that's why I played
b3 instead of taking on before and going
for those other lines I also wanted to
undermine these pawns as it's pretty
clear as soon as this Knight moves that
the the bishop on f1 you know taking on
f5 is gonna be very good so b3 was
played castles and it's definitely in my
favor to play B takes c4 so I did take
stakes and in this position I certainly
have some options I mean again I could
take this this Bishop on b4
and sacrifice my rook back as I
demonstrated but I was a little
concerned about you know ideas like
let's say even this something like f5
knight c6 and I thought that it with the
knight coming to c6 and my efore pawn
under attack it's hard for me to
maintain my d4 pawn and my e4 pawn and
even a position like this I thought it's
a little bit it's a little bit
uncomfortable maybe because that rook
stops me from castling and there's not
many chest positions where like the
entire Queen side just disappears from
the board but that's what we have here
and I thought it'd be too hard to
maintain my pawns in the center knight
c6 is always an idea and after knight c6
there's also Queen coming out to h4 and
I simply didn't want to allow any of
this stuff so I didn't I decided not to
go for that and the other main move I
considered here was Bishop to c3 but
after takes takes Knight takes d4
although I get to play this this rook d2
move black plays Knight c6 and what's
most annoying here is the Queen comes
out to be six why is that so frustrating
is I don't have a dark square Bishop
anymore and if I ever Castle it's just
gonna be sitting on the worst square 496
f3 anything any discovered to check so
it sort of means that after Queen b6 I
just can't castle and that's very
frustrating once I played pawn to f3 if
I don't have a dark square Bishop I
don't have control over that diagonal
not being able to castle is one of the
worst feelings ever especially because I
don't even have a queen side rook so I
can't even dream of castling the other
way I've got a rock on d2 right what
what was I thinking
rook a to d2 anyways so there's an
example where I thought the rook would
be useful on d2 but actually means I
can't castle and it's kind of
uncomfortable so I didn't play that
instead I played Queen b1 and I thought
okay I'm gonna attack his Bishop and I
would love if he did this because really
when you play a move like rook a to
you want to put it to use otherwise you
look like you don't know what you're
doing so I was really trying to get I
was trying to move it horizontally so
that I looked good because there are a
lot of people spectating my game and I
felt uncomfortable with my Brooklyn 82
and you know being down a lot of time on
the clock it's just embarrassing you
know
so Bishop takes D - Brooke takes D - and
now it's totally different this would be
great for me now my Brooke is protecting
the d4 pawn the bishop is hanging on b7
so I was trying to encourage this it
didn't quite work because I think I
sorta underestimated his next move which
was Queen b6 I thought there's no way
that he would make a move like this
because of rook b2 I thought that would
be so strange if he played Queen b6 and
allowed rook b2 and then I realized sort
of what he was intending here after rook
b2 this gets out of the pin because then
I'm threatening I'm threatening the King
with checked and the problem is I don't
have time for rook b7 after this because
well black can choose a number of moves
but after King takes d2 we can just
follow up with either Queen a5 or c3
check c3 check is much stronger if I
take with the let's say the night then
the real issue is that after Queen d4
Bishop d3 95 I'm not I'm not actually
doing doing anything here in fact I may
be getting seriously attacked like for
example rook takes b7 if Knight c4 check
and I play king c2 then
there's night a three just winning if
king e two again there's queen like
queen III for example and ID two
and so of course you start calculating
all these variations you realize that
there's ways to lose in in almost every
position here and did more brave King
takes c3 I mean I felt like if I had to
play this move it's probably suspicious
but Queen a5 King D 3 all with tempo
Bishop a6 King III and again after I
take Queen c3 I lose my pawn on d4 and
despite being up in exchange I have to
put my king on g3 I mean this is no fun
I thought in this position black could
play move like f5 and I would be pretty
scared of losing here f4 check is a
threat
opening up the rook is just very strong
and I'm still playing the game mostly
without my h1 rook it's not really
contributing so I was really scared of
positions like this and I only realized
that sort of after calculating and
realizing that he has this nice move
pawn to c3 initially I was counting on
rook b2 but instead I settled on Bishop
takes before not the move I initially
wanted to play so Bishop takes b4 Knight
takes and now he's very clearly
threatening Knight to d3 check and that
move is gonna win my Queen at the moment
because it's unprotected so I played
Knight to c3 so I thought okay this is
good if Queen takes here I take on b4 i
defend my knight i win a knight i'm
attacking the bishop and the night it's
a great move but he's not gonna play
that of course after Knight c3 he just
played knight c6 which is a nice move
because he strengthens his support of b4
protects his own night and the d4 pawn
is now hit by the knight and the queen
so I played rook d2 because we're on
move 18 and I hadn't touched it since I
played rook a 2 so at this point it was
a little a little too much I just had to
move it it also helped that it was being
attacked although that doesn't mean that
I needed to move it necessarily because
I did have a pin the reason that I moved
it is because the pawn on d4 is is
hanging and well I just moved my knight
from e2 to defend it and now I don't
have a good way to to support it so I
think it was around here where I started
realizing that my position is actually
just very bad it started off so good but
now I'm really missing my dark square
bishop if I had a dark square Bishop
sitting on e3 everything would be ok
everything I could play King f2 safely I
could play d5 I'd have d5 threats I
would just be covering everything
protecting my D pawn it means it's
harder for him to ever play Knight takes
d4 because he'd be walking into a pin
from my bishop but without that Bishop
as I've been saying the Queen on b6 is
so powerful at preventing me from
castling so even if I play Bishop e2
even if I Castle there's always going to
be this pin and that free pawn on d4
which is getting harder and harder to
protect what I didn't realize was that
without the dark square bishop on e3 my
knight pretty much has to stay on e - to
protect d4 and if my knight stays on e2
well then my Bishop stays on f1 and then
my King stays on e1 so everyone boxes in
something else and then none of my
pieces get developed so I played rook d2
and I realized that I didn't really have
a solution here because in the long term
if I ever Castle he can always play
Knight takes d4
he played rook e8 and at this point he
was playing pretty confidently because I
think he realized if white can't castle
then white is probably worse if my King
has to stay in the middle or face this
this attack at all then
I think it's a really uncomfortable here
93 has not been working for the last
couple moves first of all the knight on
c3 is covering my queen so it's not a
move that wins a wins material but also
after Bishop takes d3 for example my
bishop also protects my queen and
there's a number of reasons it doesn't
work but it's something I have to always
watch out for if I'm gonna leave my king
in the middle so I played Bishop e2
because I mean simply I just have to get
developed I can't wait I mean it's move
19 and that's the first time I moved my
LightSquared bishop in the whole game
broke a3
he's hitting the night once again
preparing for these ideas like rook b3
is a threat
kicking my queen out rook takes c3 is
obviously a threat winning a knight and
if I move my knight there's ideas like
c3 and pushing that pawn up the board
Bishop takes c4 in this position was you
know another move that I thought that I
could count on but again I don't really
trust the the position too much after
well let's say in a position like this
if a Knight takes d4 this is another
calculation I would have to have rook
takes and then here if Queen takes Queen
takes I have to figure out exactly
what's happening in this position
because I'm down a piece but let's say I
move like Bishop a6 might nearly win my
Bishop back because I am in a pin here
and of course it was like rook a 1 are
just extremely extremely scary to face
so I thought no matter what I'm I'm
really risking risking a big time with
Bishop takes c4 and I decided to just
play Bishop e2 and after rook a3 queen
c1 with the idea to defend my knight and
well I wish I had more ideas than that
because I'm not castling here the Queen
on b6 prevents me from castling so at
this point I think I knew I was maybe
clearly worse or maybe even losing but
it's kind of miraculous how brought
black turned a position where he's down
like a clear exchange into a position
where I sort of traded bishops dark
square bishop without thinking and now I
can't Castle I can't ever get my other
rook out and it's just a very
uncomfortable position as you can see in
the game
I never castled I never got around to it
Knight takes d4 finally it's time to
cash that in Bishop d1 there were a lot
of threats in the position but here you
know if if black played the move Knight
d3 check then I would just take it and
this rook is hanging so queen c1 the
reason I had to play Bishop d1 was
because Knight c2 is in the air so
that's not a free Brooke something like
this and what's the other unfortunate
thing is that after King d1 rook d8 mate
is even covered so nothing else nothing
else for me there nothing going in my
favor but when the position is as
tactical as this and your King stuck in
the middle you know you're sort of weak
on the dark squares generally the
tactics are gonna favor the guy who's
putting the pressure on and in that
position that is most definitely my
opponent so Brooke rook rook on a3 is
not hanging which means Bishop d1 was
played Roque a covering his last rank
also just getting the rook out of there
now 93 is a big threat and I played
Knight a for trying to keep the
initiative quote unquote of course I'm
not doing anything with my initiative
here it's all black rook takes a for his
move that was played in the game and the
idea is that he just has a really nice
sort of tactical shot here but again
it's unsurprising that the guy who's
been putting on the pressure at the
entire game has the tactics I mean you
can't expect to sit here play white
position and then expect the tactics to
just work out for you I mean White's
position is almost all his pieces are
misplaced and this is a
nice I can speak about White's position
almost like a a third person as if it's
not my game like whites position is so
bad here I mean you should never never
play like this is ridiculous
and then of course I've got my name
right up there at the top saying that
actually belongs to me that's kind of
embarrassing
tonight a four rook takes a four and I
didn't see this in the game but again my
moves are kind of forced I have to play
Bishop takes and he sort of uncorks this
really nice combo it plays Knight takes
a free check and I thought at this point
I said well I'm either gonna lose a
really kind of pretty game or you know
he's not gonna have enough material to
checkmate me because he's running it I
mean he's healthy got a queen a knight
and a bishop after I play pawn takes so
I thought okay maybe I'm up so much
material here that even though he takes
a lot of it back maybe he can't take all
of it back unfortunately I was wrong
Queen III check annoying move I've only
got a couple options here because rookie
two drops my Queen King d1 is not the
move I played in the game it's the other
option Queen f3 check and the reason
that I wasn't really playing it is
because after Queen f3 rookie - first of
all Queen takes h1 is with check and
then maybe Queen takes Queen is is close
to a good very very good position but
he's got even better he's got a 93 here
and well now if I play let's say Queen
takes c4 Knight B to my rook spin so I
lose my whole queen here and it means in
this position white actually has to play
a different move let's say Queen c3 but
if you can't take that pawn on c4 and
free for your pieces then okay in this
position basically Black has brought the
material back to three pawns plus a
night for rook and on top of those three
pawns
he's also got nearly a checkmating
attack so this would be pretty bad for
me
I decided to play King f1 because it's
the move that appears to keep my
material because after Queen takes f3 I
could play King g1 so I think it's
logical I played King f1 as opposed to
the other one because you know at least
he still has to prove something here he
has to check meet me and unfortunately
he was up to the task
so Queen III King f1 Queen f3 King g1
these moves were just played based on
the time situation so he just shuffled a
little bit and then he made his next
intended move but ok we we were both
getting a little low on time and he
thought as is a good strategy in chess
to just repeat and gain a few moves to
words move 40 so 93 this is the move
that he came up with and it's it's
unfortunate but there's no no real
trickery with Queen takes e4 because not
only is Queen e1 just Shaq and then take
with Czech but even if it was White's
turn there's no Queen c8 mate
so I'm not threatening anything here so
on top of not threatening anything
I'm also hanging like every single piece
I own so I decided to play h4 kind of a
creative move if I play age 40 you
understand my idea is that this Queen is
off limits because of checkmate this is
not the kind of tactic that you can
expect to work at this stage in the game
but I had my hopes 93 h4 other moves in
age 4 I would just have to move my queen
let's say Queen maybe d1 is another move
and if we calculate here where my king
is gonna go it doesn't have many places
to go after Queen f4 so here if King e2
then we have a checkmate
if King g2 then unfortunately for me
that bishop that has been back there
joins the attack for the first time in
the game and basically this was a
position I was quite sure was leading to
checkmate okay King h3 the problem is
that the rooks are hanging in this
position that if black wants to he could
sort of play materially but during the
game I was just quite convinced that
something like this would lead to mate
Queen takes e4 is also possible here
Queen takes e4 h1 is hanging because I
mean even a position like like this for
example King g3 let's say even this we
have to remember that black is how many
pawns did he just take he's got four
pawns plus the night here so it's
probably winning anyway but again I'm
sure there's a checkmate there as well
that with just a little bit of thought
it's very easy to find so I decided to
play age for Queen f4 check King g1
Queen III check King f1 again my
opponent wasting a few moves to get to
move 40 just in case he would need them
this game didn't actually even make it
that long c3 very nice move
why does c3 just work well the issue is
that of Queen takes c3 Queen e1 King g2
and again the Bishop joins the attack
which you get that feeling that the
queen of the night are basically
dominating two rocks in my queen as soon
as Jesus throws one more piece into the
attack I don't have any answers if my
King goes to h1 or h3 here or start each
two or h3 here black is going to take
one of these things and then probably
take the other so something like this
already I could basically just rule this
out
Queen g1 check and the King doesn't have
many places to go there's no rook g2
King h3 let's say Bishop f5 Knight f4 I
mean you guys pick whichever mate you
like so that position looked hopeless so
I have to leave my queen on c1 but at
the same time my rook is attacked and if
I move my rook somewhere then my queen
is hanging because my queen is only not
hanging because of this checkmate idea
so if I go and play like rook here well
that just doesn't work I'll just take a
free Queen
so I played rook H - H - if he takes my
rook I'm hoping to take back but I mean
he's ruthless he's way too accurate for
me he plays the move Bishop a6 and I
mean at some point now it's like I was
like well aren't you a little concerned
there mr. Ganguly about not taking all
your material back you know if you do a
count it can be a little intimidating
I've got two rooks for a knight but no
he's pretty cold-blooded played Bishop
a6 and he's saying once again that if
Queen takes on c3 that black will play
let's say when we play after Queen c3
probably some discovered discovered
check here you have to remember the king
doesn't have anywhere to go so if I play
Knight f4 my king is actually stuck it
doesn't have anywhere to move which
means that I need to block this check
with my pieces and unfortunately these
are the worst set of pieces that could
ever possibly be arranged to block this
check pick Bishop e5 know what I mean I
have to play like rook here takes takes
and at the end of the day it's just me
completely winning so I just can't block
this check that's the horse part I just
can't block the check so I can't take it
well if I can't take it I've got to deal
with this discovered check again I can't
block it so rook hd2
and I mean when you when you got guys
playing queen takes you to check against
you it really starts to get embarrassing
at this point there's there's people
coming to the board they're all looking
my Brooke on d2 that was the same one
that started on a two so at least it
made it to the end of the game but queen
take c2 I mean I follow up with Brooke
take c2 Knight takes c1 and I lose my
rook I follow up with King take c2 well
not really any different takes
that's check as well then the rook falls
so I mean it's just it's just over so he
played Queen take c2 and I just resigned
after Queen takes because quite honestly
I had had enough I mean that was a
pretty brutal game he played Queen e2
and he won the game after what I would
say was kind of lazy preparation on my
part because I looked a little bit at
the engine eval and sort of comforted
myself that white was doing well but
there are some games there and there
were some games before I played him of
other strong players like even Nakamura
who tries this line from time to time
and it does trend in in blacks direction
not the whole line but the way that I
played with f3 this greedy move early on
to try to keep the pawn in the center
and just have a solid structure in the
end black does well in a lot of those
positions because despite the computer
evaluation it's just a really comfy
comfy position with easy plans and
that's exactly what my opponent did here
is completely familiar with what to do I
wasn't so I was using a lot of time and
I also didn't play very convincingly
here as I probably made some like you
know cardinal mistakes like don't give
away the dark square bishop in this line
all these things that I basically wasn't
prepared to handle because I just sort
of checked the the evaluation on the
computer and rationalized that this
would be safe to play but clearly he had
prepared this either for himself or for
another another player
and he was super well well-prepared
against me and it showed I mean I got
kind of destroyed it ended up being 34
moves but it felt like I was I was
getting pushed around for you know the
whole game so I guess this this kind of
qualifies as one of my greater greatest
losses because I was impressed by the
game as it was happening to me this
Knight takes f3 that he had and then
this Queen Queen sac at the end and just
the comfort level being like so down so
much material but still not trying to
just win it back he's playing for the
compensation he's playing to check me my
king he's not worried about getting his
pieces back you can see he cashed in
big-time right at the end of the game
and he got everything back at once so
that was probably the correct way to
play and yeah he just launched a really
successful attack so he kind of crushed
me here and he also crushed my hopes at
a GM norm which was in that tournament I
was an international master at the time
back in 2015 and yeah so this this was a
tough loss of mine against Ganguly who
is still still a strong player to this
day I have a I have another game which
is kind of like a like a bonus greatest
loss because while this game is is my
greatest loss in the sense that I
thought it was beautiful game by my
opponent and it was really unexpected to
me the whole time the other game that I
that I have prepared is without a quite
what out question it's my worst loss as
in it felt the worst I mean when you
lose like this it doesn't actually feel
that bad the guy played a really good
game it's quite impressive and if you
kind of deserved it the the other game
that I that I prepared it's really tough
to take it's really tough to take this
loss was was probably where I was let's
say the most upset after the game or you
know one of the worst ways to lose and
hopefully I'll show you what I mean
so this game this game was played at a
Canadian Open in Canada there we go and
it was played against a guy named
Nikolai in Ritson and Nikolai for those
that don't know him was involved in a
very funny scandal in chess where he was
playing for the Canadian championship
very recently and his opponent was like
hiding the Queen that he needed to
promote he couldn't find his Queen and
so he promoted to an upside-down rook
and then that's an illegal move and so
it doesn't count as a Queen accounted as
a rook and then he ended up losing the
game so he was part of a very funny
controversy recently a very unfortunate
one as the playoff that that game
happened in was a qualifier for the
World Cup so he ended up losing his spot
for that but this is way before that
this is in 2011 so where was I in 2011 I
was fm so I had made FM in 2009 and this
was just a local tournament in Canada
but the Canadian Open and used to be a
lot stronger back then so I don't want
to focus too much on the game but I did
want to just run through it quickly from
the start to really give you an idea why
this is let's say a loss that still
haunts me to this day because it doesn't
really do it justice to just show the
final position so we'll go through it a
little quickly here but essentially we
got a benoni style position Kings Indian
but it's probably going to go in the
direction of e6 for black ideas like e6
ideas like b5 these are all typical
benoni structure ideas
Queen d2 gaining time hitting the pawn
on h6 castle and my opponent plays b5 so
he's saying you can have this pawn and
I'll take the pawn in the center
I played Bishop takes g6 Queen takes d5
so technically I want to pawn there but
I did give my opponent the two bishops
as well as a very mobile pawn center if
you can play d5 d4 no that's tough ask
because d5 then the C pawn hangs but if
he can play d5 d4 he's in a very good
position
I think the LightSquared bishop is very
dangerous on the long diagonal as well
rook b8 r okay d1
don't forget that dark square Bishop on
g7 very very good hitting the pawn on b2
it can be taken in a lot of lines so I
didn't want him to take my pawn on b2
and he also tried to stop me from taking
his pawn on d6 and it came over me that
this was a good move to play okay I
don't know if that's true I was an FM at
the time so you know thinking like an FM
calculating like an FM Bishop g5 that
looks like an FM among those probably
not the same move I played today so what
did I want
I wanted to two pieces for the rook but
not only did I get a pawn there I want
to say that the pawn on g6 is hanging
and that maybe I have next move
something like rook e1 and either rookie
7 or rook e8 seemed like I had decent
compensation King h7 rook e1 rook d7
handles both of those moves kind of
nicely and after rook e8 I think I
realized in this position that again two
pawns plus a rook for the bishop should
probably be totally fine but when ended
up happening was that I think that I
just got kind of outplayed by my
opponent here he started to outplay me
and I wanted to get rid of this pawn
really badly the C pawn is hanging but
there's ideas like Bishop f8 that I have
to watch out for I can't just go grab
that pawn h5 g5 and my ideas I finally
get this pawn
and I take here so I thought that had a
good chance to draw because so far we've
liquidated I'm hoping to get rid of that
a pawn but I'm also thinking in some
lines if the rooks come off the board
that that Bishop is the wrong color for
the a1 square so this is me thinking
pretty far ahead but I was like yeah I
probably have good drawing chances
because even if I trade the rooks it's a
it's actually a draw work a2 and I give
up the the Jeep on here in order to
basically just walk my King all the way
over to this side of the board and once
I do that my idea is b4r okay six
something along the lines of those two
moves and trade this pawn and get a
broke against rook and Bishop not that
that's like a clear draw or anything but
it's probably the best I can do and it
is technically a draw although in
practice people do lose that in game a
lot people lose that endgame a lot okay
so he tries to keep his pawn but after a
few moves that be pawn of mine just runs
so far up the board that you can see I
was able to corral his pawn and take
here so we're gonna go to the point
where let's say he captures the pawn so
move 56 he captures the pawn because I
think at the time I was still writing
down move so we're playing with
increment and of course when you see
King takes h5 now after this move which
is a capture we're finally in we're
finally in the endgame where I should
probably start counting to 50 for the 50
move rule and luckily we were still
writing down the move so I could just
circle the score sheet you know it's
much easier sometimes when you're
playing on a dgt board and let's say
you're playing a blitz tournament and
you don't write down the moves you
should always call an arbiter tell them
to start counting for you otherwise
there's no no proof but I still have my
square sheet so I circled nice big
circle and move fifty six or let's say
move fifty seven as the first move
and we see my attempted defense here
trying to say on the dark squares
I played rook c8 because I thought well
if I'm defending this endgame I may as
well try to look nice and cute by doing
it so we'll go set up a little draw
trick you wouldn't believe how quickly
he played not that move but check and
check and King III whenever your
opponent sets a trap that kind of looks
pretty usually you want to play really
really fast so that you let him know
that you obviously saw that in like
there's no no way you ever considered
such a bad move so I think that's that's
what was happening here I know that's
what I do
that's what I do so we see this this
technique we're right now move 72 so
we're still we're still going along but
I was waiting for you know my opponent
to sort of make some progress because so
far more or less I've I've kept my king
away from the sides of the board and
that's the first step is to to get
White's King to the side of the board so
so far I was able to decent job but now
finally I move 86 I was forced to the
side and we remember that back on move
56 or 57 lets it out that was the big
circle 57 was the first was the first
move there so Bishop d3 now my opponent
is trying to do setup that I mean at
this point we're actually maybe in a
some sort of position where maybe
officially black is winning based on the
engine or officially white is drawing I
didn't really know but at this point I
was just following what seemed logical
to me which was rook c7 dealing with
rook check here and then when when I
have the option was to just give him
checks and then broke e 7 to block the
check on this side so that's sort of
what I was what I was going with here is
my defense at the time I can say I
definitely had not looked at this
endgame
I mean you can study this endgame in
fact you should but as an FM back in
2011 nope no
chance I mean I'm more likely to go
memorize in theory or go study an
opening or learn something else or you
know go play a sport then study this
endgame nowadays I probably wish I did
otherwise this game might not be part of
this lecture
rookie 7 so I'm always ready to meet
rook f1 check with rook e1 and we can
see I'm sort of going along and we've
almost had this position before so I
thought okay I mean this is very good I
look at my move 102 so I'm I'm kind of
counting like the moves until until the
move 52 50 move roll so he plays rook
over here and in this position I mean
very clearly he's threatening rook down
here checkmate
because the bishops covering this square
and I felt like I had almost had this
position before but somehow in fact I
hadn't exactly had it not quite so king
e1 just runs into me
I can't block the me and I can't stop at
king c1 is actually the only move and
then I have to route b6 I was like wait
a minute
now I'm getting made it by force and the
only way to not get made it of course is
to well give up the rook let's say rook
takes e4 or rook b8 but no matter what
move I make he's gonna let say capture
something so he's gonna play King takes
e4 rook takes B it doesn't matter but no
matter what it's it's a capture and that
gets rid of the 50 move rule of course
that makes sense
can't just be hanging my pieces and
counting to 50 moves so I played rook c8
because at this point I saw I was
getting made it but I was like wow it's
been how many moves has it been I mean
I've been here for four hours this was
coming up to like almost eight hour game
it's like seven and a half hours and I
played rook c8 but I didn't hit my clock
and do all that I sort of wrote down
rook c8 or intended to play rook c8 and
I raised my hand I called the arbiter
and I did a fifty move
rule claim and I said okay this is 50
moves so they go back and they tally up
the the moves and let's remember that
I'll move fifty six black played King
takes age five black played it so that
means on blacks 56 plus 50th move 106 it
would be 50 moves so we fast forward to
move 106 I made the move rook c8 on move
106 my opponent will play the move
checkmate
but at the moment right now 50 moves
technically haven't been made 49 and a
half have been made so that's not a 50
move that's a forty nine and a half move
rule and that doesn't exist so the claim
was refuted was denied and correctly so
of course which meant that I just
resigned on the spot I had to it was
like it was like one last-ditch thing
where you just arbiter I'd like to claim
a draw otherwise I'd like to resigned
and take a hike that's exactly what I
did so I lost trying to defend and then
claim a 50 move rule and the game
actually was forty nine and a half moves
but not 50 and this was basically that
the end of a you know seven and a half
eight hour game and you go out like this
to to a forty nine and a half move
attempted claim that just wasn't wasn't
to be and it almost felt like in the
last couple moves somehow I got lazy
because I was looking at my score she
and I saw the big circle next to 106 and
I was like hey we're almost there
there's a couple couple more moves you
know just let's just finish this off and
I actually got myself mated somehow and
the last four moves of the game and then
I couldn't even get myself out of out of
it with a claim so kind of ridiculous
but shows that you can't really take
your foot off the gas
and I ended up losing this game and I I
haven't I haven't really had this
endgame since so I haven't had the
chance that you know prove that I can
last half a move longer but I'm very
excited for that chance for now this is
definitely one of the the losses in my
chess career that stung the most let's
say felt the worst afterwards of course
it's not in a good mood don't know who
could be but yeah forty nine and a half
moves this was one of the worst that I
remember cuz I did play it while I was a
decent player and I was an FM and yeah
this one this one felt the worst it
wasn't like I was playing for prize
prize money or first place or anything
like that it was round seven it was like
almost an eight hour game it was against
another Canadian who you know definitely
a rival just we played each other quite
a lot over the years growing up in the
scene together and yeah I mean nothing
feels worse than that it's like such a
long game and then a big fat zero in the
result column which is you know I could
have had that result way earlier I could
I could have lost a game in 20 moves but
nope I decided to go 106 and then and
then lose 106 106.5
I should say or 105.5 I mean that sounds
like a radio station that's that's
embarrassing so there you go those are
two of my my pretty bad losses but this
one especially stung the most although
it wasn't necessarily against like very
strong player you know like world-class
player and the guy crushes me in in a
very nice game this was sort of a
different type of loss he's a strong
player but it was more funny how it
turned out forty nine and a half moves
at the end the first game though against
Ganguly was that one was a very
impressive game by my opponent and
kind of kind of caught me off guard so
one of the nicest players out there
Ganguly really nice guy and just totally
crushed me in that game so these were a
couple games that refresh in my mind
even though they're actually played a
while ago four years ago for one of them
just eight years ago for this one I'm
getting old but yeah those are there was
some of the most memorable maybe not for
the best reasons but I guess that's kind
of the point of this class so yeah there
you go that's it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you